hi everybody my name is Lea Jarrett and
I'm a product demonstrations manager at
looker today I'm going to be talking
about how our customers here at Google
cloud have been using data powered by
bigquery and looker to make data-driven
responses to Kovan 19 I'm gonna start by
talking about the impetus for creating
this data block that I'll go into in a
bit I'm going to talk about how our
customers were coming to us and needed
to analyze all this public of it
publicly available data for koban 19 and
then I'm going to jump into a very quick
overview of looker and bigquery just to
give you context on the different tools
we're using next I'm going to walk
through the actual marketplace block
that looker team has launched with the
bigquery public data sets team and last
I'm going to talk through a couple of
our customer stories and how they've
actually used the marketplace block that
we have created to make data-driven
responses so like I said we began
getting a lot of requests for our from
our customers asking how they can use
our tools here at Google cloud to
actually analyze all the data that was
becoming available from kovat 19 as a
product demonstrations manager at looker
I'm responsible for creating different
demonstrations of how we can use looker
to analyze various data sets so many
people on our team were reaching out to
me asking how do we create a demo to
show how we can actually use looker and
bigquery to analyze all of this data we
were getting requests from all different
industries we had government offices
contacting us who needed data to
understand how they can create different
policies and state mitigations to better
limit the spread of the disease we had
different healthcare institutions that
were coming to our sales teams and our
engineers asking how they could use data
to prepare for an influx of cases across
the world and of course we had all of
our other businesses ecommerce companies
real estate
companies all asking us you know how can
we really make use of all the data
that's become available and join it back
with our own data so we can make
insightful decisions and better prepare
our business for what's happening in the
world at the start of copán 19 different
institutions started releasing data you
could hop on Google and see tons of
different data sources different
companies various via biomedical
institutions and universities were all
coming out with publicly available
datasets showing both testing rates and
infection rates across the world it was
really overwhelming amount of data so
our customers were continuously coming
to us trying to figure out what data
sources to use how to use these data
sources and to make matters more
confusing each data source had its own
definitions with its own schema so it
was really difficult to understand where
do we start what data sources do we use
and then what do we actually do with
those data sources so just want to make
a quick note about the bigquery public
data sets program the bigquery public
data sets program took a large amount of
these different data sources created
definition so you've clearly understood
what those data sources where they came
from what the metrics meant and of
course they take care of all that
ETL the getting the data into the actual
database for you each day so that all of
our bigquery customers can simply query
this data and have it available without
needing to figure out what data sources
they should use and how they could get
it into their own databases the problem
with using this data set is you know our
analysts at all of our customers still
needed to figure out what to do with
this data and they also had to create
the queries directly in bigquery to get
answers to their own questions
so of course bigquery is a database that
Google cloud powers but you really need
to understand sequel in order to be able
to ask questions of the
data a lot of our customers have
analysts who are familiar with using
sequel but that means we're limiting who
actually can ask questions of the data
we really need that technical resource
to be the person who's going in and
asking the questions for us this is
where looker comes in and just to give
everyone a bit of background on looker
if you don't already know looker is a
data platform and it's going to sit
directly on top of your sequel database
so in this case we're talking about
sitting directly on top of our public
data sets available in bigquery now
looker is powered by a git version
controlled modeling layer that we call
look ml what look ml allows us to do is
actually create a data dictionary of all
of our different metrics we use raw
sequel to define those calculations and
then business users folks who are not
familiar with writing sequel queries can
jump in into the looker platform
slice and dice data create new reports
export the data schedule it basically
they're empowered to go in and ask new
questions of this data without needing
to rely on a technical resource this was
also really important for us because
like I mentioned before the data that
was published with Kovan 19 was not
exactly straightforward we had different
companies that were defining metrics in
different ways we had data that was
getting updated at different frequencies
and putting this all together we had a
whole team of analysts here at looker
trying to work on creating that look ml
modeling layer to look at the metrics
related to koban 19 so to give you a
little bit of background we had you know
maybe 10 or 15 of our sales engineers
jumping in reading up on the data
learning the data sources understanding
the calculations that were coming out on
places like New York Times or for Johns
Hopkins and we were creating our own
look at male model to look at those
calculations things like number of new
cases that were emerging each day daily
growth rates average growth rates across
different regions and we had a
pretty robust process for going through
our calculations testing things making
things that making sure everything was
working appropriately now of course we
we did all this to basically create
these product demonstrations to show our
customers hey this is how you can
actually analyze this data but after
going through this effort we realized we
should make this model that we've
created available to all of our
customers so that they don't have to go
through this same process that we just
went through this is where lookers
marketplace comes into play lookers
marketplace is an in-app marketplace so
on your looker instance you can go up go
directly into the marketplace and
install what we call blocks these blocks
are really just pre-built
pieces of look ml so that's equal based
modeling layer that can help you you
know be making data decisions data
driven decisions faster what I mean by
this is we don't want our customers
spending all their time trying to
understand what the different data sets
mean where they're coming from
how often things are updated when
they're calculated we want our customers
to be actually using the data to make
those data-driven decisions for their
business because that's what they're
best at doing so our team after creating
this look ml model we decided to publish
it into the looker marketplace what this
means for our customers is anyone could
go in to the marketplace click a button
download the marketplace block into
their local instance and have our model
that we've created available for them to
use so that they're really accelerating
their time to value when it came to
these public data sets so when our
customers go and install this block into
their looker instance they're going to
get a few things first off they're going
to get two dashboards that are
international dashboards one on the
left-hand side is where you can see
International view of what's happening
across the world this data is primarily
you know powered by Johns Hopkins in the
New York Times and some other data
sources that show things like testing or
or government decisions on the
right-hand side we can see a dashboard
that's focused on Italy now this is
because the Italian government published
a few different data sets that talk in
depth about the case spread across Italy
next we have two other dashboards that
focus on the United States first we have
a view of the entire United States where
we can see things like hospital bed
utilization and infection rates across
the country from here we can drill down
into a brand new dashboard which focuses
on a single state and it shows you all
the way down to county level information
we're also able to see what the
mitigation and policy response has been
for that state and of course we can
change filters to only narrow down to
look at a couple of counties within that
state or compare multiple states with
each other one other thing I wanted to
mention is that more recently we've
decided to publish another block into
the marketplace focused on the mobility
data that's been published by Google
this data talks about patterns and
mobility across the United States and
with both of these blocks installed on
your look or instance you can see this
data side-by-side and get a clearer view
of how mobility patterns have been
correlated with different infection
spread across the country
now when you download this block into
the market into your looker instance you
get those dashboards but even better is
you have the Explorer environment to
actually go and slice and dice the data
and ask brand new questions as I
mentioned before any business user can
hop in and ask these questions while
looker is simply compiling that sequel
query and sending it back to bigquery on
your behalf
now we notice that this information can
be confusing and since it's such
sensitive data it's really important for
us to make sure that our customers
understand exactly what these numbers
mean and how they were calculated that's
why here you can see some screenshots
I've taken where you have all the
different tooltips that show
descriptions of how the metrics were
calculated descriptions of what kind of
questions you can ask in this data
exploration environment and links to all
the data sources so you can go directly
to the source and understand things like
how they've collected the data and last
of course you get that look or modeling
layer that's powering this entire
experience like I mentioned that
modeling layer acts as a data dictionary
where we basically have this dictionary
of all of our metrics that are powering
both the Explorer environment and
they're powering those dashboards but
what's really interesting about
Marketplace blocks and looker is that
you can actually extend the block and
you can change the actual base
configuration so modify that data
dictionary so that it fits your needs
and better yet you can extend it and
join it back on with your own data and
this is the real power of this block and
this is kind of our impetus for
releasing a block like this is we want
you and all of our customers to join it
back on your data so you can get
increased insights into what's really
happening and how it's affecting your
business specifically so I hope that
after this presentation you're going to
go ahead and check out the looker
marketplace we have a lot of
documentation available on how you can
use these blocks and how you can modify
them for your own needs
additionally we wanted to make sure that
you clearly understand how the modeling
layer is working so we had our team of
sales engineers go in and write clear
documentation
you know robust comments to really make
sure that you're understanding each
calculation that's performed now what I
want to talk about is a couple of our
customers who are actually using this
that we've built to help them make
decisions for their business during this
difficult time the first I want to talk
about is HCA and HCA is one of the
nation's leading health care providers
at the start of COBIT they came to us
with a goal of creating a national
response portal the goal of this
national response portal was to give
healthcare administrators and government
officials a singles place to monitor the
spread of this disease across the
country so that they can make better
informed decisions on both hospital
administration tasks like staffing and
utilization of resources and also for
our government officials to be making
data informed decisions on policies so
HCA worked with one of our partners sada
to build out this portal that any of the
nation's providers can opt into and also
contribute data to what's really
powerful about what HCA did is they took
the data that we had worked with in our
block all this publicly available data
that's in bigquery but they went ahead
and joined it on their own proprietary
data from these hospitals this data
centered around things like ventilator
and ICU bed utilization so that
hospitals can log in at any moment focus
on one geography and see real-time
analytics about what's going on in that
area and of course make better plans for
the future based on the information that
they're seeing
now although koban 19 was what inspired
this national response portal to be
created HCA hopes that this will live on
because obviously this framework is
going to be really important for other
diseases and just general Public Health
the next customer I'm going to talk
about is Diamond Resorts I'm sure many
of you have heard of Diamond Resorts
they're a timeshare company with
vacation spots around the whole world
when the pandemic hit I'm sure you all
realized that travel and leisure was one
of the industries that was hit hardest
from the beginning people were probably
nerve
to travel and of course there were
restrictions being placed on where you
could travel where you were going to and
where you could come from
so Diamond Resorts had an influx of
requests coming from their customers
about rescheduling their vacations
cancelling their vacations and Diamond
Resorts really needed a way to adapt to
this influx of requests so what they did
was they use this block as well and he
used looker to analyse his Cove in 19
data analyze it alongside their own data
around who is rescheduling who is
cancelling and try to predict when are
people going to want to reschedule where
will they be rescheduling their trips
and basically use all this information
to plan appropriately so that they're
they're helping their customers get
through this difficult time
and ensure that they'll be able to
reschedule these vacations when it's
safe to do so and where and when they
want to go the last customer I'm going
to talk about today is garden and garden
delivers healthy food and snacks to
offices around the country so of course
you can imagine that when offices shut
down in most of the major cities in the
United States Garden aided a way to
adapt to this change now that things are
beginning to reopen or we see you know
changes in our society Garten needed a
way to basically plan for this reopening
and try to understand what offices would
be reopening what capacity would they be
reopening at what they have half of
their employees coming back to work
would they only have a handful and
basically come up with programs that are
going to support these offices as we're
going through this influx of changes so
Garten went ahead and they used the the
looker block as well and just like the
other companies I've talked about they
were able to look at this data alongside
their own data around you know what
customers they have how many employees
these customers have where they are in
the United States and basically come up
with those programs
to fulfill their customers needs so I
just want to take time to say thank you
all for for you know joining us here
today and listening to how our customers
are using all this technology and data
to make these data-driven responses I
really encourage you to go understand
more about bigquery public data sets
program also the liquor marketplace and
you can find really useful information
about this block that we've created in
this link that I've posted here one of
our you know friends here looker have
decided to create a blog post that goes
into detail on why we decided to create
this block what data we used for our
block and also has a link to a publicly
accessible dashboard and explorer
environment so that if you want to be
able to analyze the data yourself you
can go to this website and create your
own reports drill into data get a feel
for what you would be experiencing with
liquor so thank you